[Music]
[Applause]
uh Dan Wetzel Yahoo sports columnist and
New York Times bestselling author he's
been working on the Michigan
situation what do you think is going to
happen today with Michigan if
anything uh I don't think anything will
happen today I think we'll go tomorrow
and it'll be down to what uh the Big 10
wants to do um Michigan's going to
respond on today to the Big 10 and then
I think the Big 10 will probably have a
decision tomorrow or maybe Friday uh do
they want to suspend Jim Harbaugh uh
indefinitely that is on the table uh
until the end of the NCA investigation
uh do they want to just give him two
games three games would be the rest of
the regular season two games uh or they
could back off and and not do anything
but uh it's a precarious spot for
Harbaugh uh right now considering what
the big 10 uh is sending out there as
poss punishments do you think there's a
negotiation going on between Michigan
and the nciaa Andor Big 10 oh there's
there's absolutely a negotiation going
on I don't know whether they will reach
any
negotiation um we'll see how dug in
everybody is you know it's hard to th
we've never seen this Dan I mean a a
commissioner suspending a head
coach let alone of a winning team in the
middle of the season I I I've been
covering College atics for you know a
couple decades I've never heard anything
like this in in in this element not uh
you know they went after the ref too
hard or you know something like that um
but while there's an investigation going
on and you know I think look what Connor
stallions did was
clearly attempt to violate the rules and
and to help Michigan um if the nca's now
3-we investigation had covered any ties
or knowledge proof that Jim Harbaugh
knew or even up to like his coordinators
knew then Harbaugh should be fired
immediately by Michigan but that hasn't
materialized so to to make this big of
an aggressive move when an
investigation's ongoing and it's not
like hey there's a text message here
saying hey Connor you should go to the
central Michigan game oh thanks Coach
Harbaugh should I wear the sunlasses yes
ABS you know like if you got something
like that gone but without that kind of
any knowledge in it it appears
you know we'll see maybe they find
something today but they haven't found
anything this is a unprecedented move
and so unprecedented negotiations and
really no one knows what the what the
big 10 will do but it is a uh is quite a
precedent for the Big 10 to to make a
move on Jim Harbaugh in the middle of an
investigation yeah I keep cautioning
people like do process let's just let it
play out everybody wants to get to the
end of the story suspend har ball
Michigan can't play for a national
championship ship I I want to know what
is there like we keep hearing that could
have happened you know everything's on
the periphery I need to know exactly
okay you got Jim Harbaugh and Michigan
dead to rights this guy acting on his
own did he share the information with uh
a coordinator did that coordinator tell
Jim Harbaugh is Jim Harbaugh sort of the
way patino was at Louisville hey he
didn't know about the hookers but he
should have known about the hookers
right I'm I I I just I'm waiting for the
there there Dan well there's a couple
things here and and be clear I'm not
saying that Michigan just should Escape
penalty or they didn't they didn't
violate the rules but I think there is
perspective that needs to happen and to
you know two things nobody cared about
sign stealing until three weeks ago I
mean nobody cared about sign stealing
they steal their signs each other signs
they Advance Scout all the time they
just have their friends and other
coaching staffs hand over their work uh
I mean this is that the whole Scandal is
like out of nowhere because if somebody
investigated this and hoped the NCA and
the Big 10 would overreact and we have
overreacted so we're going to see
whether they still will overreact but
this is not the biggest Scandal uh on
Earth that said it is something
um what we have a lot of and a lot of
the way this story was framed is
anonymous coaches
screaming that he should have known he
must have known he had to have known all
that stuff and Tony batiti having
meetings with the the coaches and the
ads of the other schools and listening
to him like that's the last group you
would listen to I wouldn't want to hear
Jim Harbaugh's opinion on something
going on at Ohio State because I would
just dismiss it out of hand so a lot of
this is like well this is the big this
is terrible this is awful they're doing
the same thing just in a different way
they all are stealing signs and they are
all using Advanced Scouts depending on
how you define them in different ways to
steal those signs and so you can't you
know I caution I don't really care what
happens here right I I caution anybody
who says you know an organization that
says well we're just going to go on it
because we're going to suspend Jim
Harbaugh for the rest of the year
because we think he should have known
that isn't how it should work and if
it's too slow or whatever but what if he
didn't I mean on the second day of this
I looked at this this case differently
than most and I thought what I see is
Connor
stallions this is this was my possible
theory on the case and maybe it proves
to be wrong it hasn't yet Connor
stallion is a guy in his 20s
overeager wants to be the Michigan head
coach one day has a 600 page Manifesto
about how he'll be the head coach and
what he'll do he gets attention as a
young coach for being able to decipher
these codes and break the codes and he's
from the Naval Academy and he's selling
himself as this this wizard at it and
Michigan knows he's stealing the codes
they they know they're breaking down the
signals they just don't know how he's
putting his Thum on the scale to be so
good at it he's not going to volunteer
that information because it makes him
look a guilty get him fired or less of a
genius so he's pumping himself up and
not telling anyone most conspiracies in
this country although everyone wants to
believe they're vast they're usually
very small I don't think there is a very
very plausible case that he told no one
and acted on his own I don't know that
that's it but there's a very plausible
explanation on that I think everybody
including the NCA and the Big 10 went
running in saying Harbaugh had to know
everybody had to know Michigan had to
know and when you're going in on that
route and then you're not even doing due
process you put yourself over a barrel
and you open Pandora's Box and so
whether Jim Harbaugh gets suspended or
not or Michigan gets punish many of
those things should happen I just would
caution anyone to just say well we have
one world view here and it's because a
bunch of other football coaches who
aren't really paying attention aren't
really deep thinkers just want Jim
Harbaugh gone that's a dangerous way for
the NCA and the Big 10 to operate and
it's dangerous for all the other coaches
too because today it's Harbaugh tomorrow
it's
you if I said that you could find out
what Harbaugh knew or find out who gift
WRA this investigation for the
NCA uh well which would I choose
yeah
uh I'm of I I'm of the believe Harbaugh
didn't know um now should he should he
have been more Curious should he have
been more uh I think I know that I think
Harbaugh didn't know I should he should
he have been more Curious should he have
been more walking in that grad grad
assistant room yelling anybody breaks a
rule and costs me my job I'm gonna kill
you you know all that stuff he he's
terrible manager of his staff right he's
got all sorts problems it's not
pertinent to the case who hired the pi
it it it doesn't matter but I don't
really care what H I don't care about
about sence steal I don't care what
Michigan's SP as purely a media vulture
yeah I want to know who hired him
because somebody hired them hoping the
NCA would fall for the okey dooke and go
with this and not think this through and
it worked perfectly and if nothing else
done to tip my cap at whoever plotted
this thing out they weren't really
outraged by sign stealing uh is my guess
there's not a sign stealing uh you know
hardcore anti- sign stealer out there
that just said this is too much they
wanted to get Michigan they got Michigan
for the soap opera aspect that I like
I'd want to know that good to talk to
you Dan thanks for joining us thanks Dan
Dan Wetzel Yahoo sports columnist New
York Times best-selling author yeah
we've talked about if these other
schools are sharing signs are they
guilty of doing sort of the same thing
that Michigan is guilty of or at least
accused
of maybe we find out something today
maybe Michigan is trying to negotiate
something here
um Jim Harbaugh keeps saying never got
to him maybe it didn't but let's let it
play out it's it's when we jump to the
end because everybody has to have a hot
take don't have a hot take make a phone
call do some investigation report on
this not oh it must be guilty okay oh
you got to fire okay I just want to know
you know a couple of things do the
coordinators know anything and that's
where I would ask I would start start
there with the coordinators with
Michigan if I'm big 10 I go come on
in uh who did he share the information
with did you two coordinators get any
information they got two really good
coordinators by the way at Michigan
offens and defensive coordinator I just
want to know he Shar that information
with you did you share that with
Coach all right get my answers there at
least start there but as far as
suspending him two games $10,000 that's
what they're allowed to but if it goes
for more than that if you suspend him
indefinitely does Michigan fight this
Michigan fights this until the end of
the season they're still investigating
Michigan for what happened during coid
with recruiting they're not going to get
around to this till Harbaugh is in the
NFL in a couple years or maybe back in
college after being in the NFL like man
oh man